GPT5在暑假下段終於千呼萬喚始出來
但你知道Open AI其實更新了很多隱藏功能沒有在發表會跟你說嗎
今天這集影片
我們就來帶大家一次了解這一波Chat GPT大更新的幾個超讚的秘密功能
嗨大家好我又是我AJ GPT5問世已經兩個禮拜了
你各位不知道用下來感想如何呢
雖然說最近網絡上哀嚎不斷
人人都說GPT5變得冷血又無情
搞得好像性轉一樣 但我跟製作人用下來的感覺是 嗯 好啦給過
很多人在私信敲網想要看GPT5的用戶跟模型更新
我們會在下個禮拜的時候一次跟大家做一個大解析
如果看到這邊請先訂閱一下
下周才可以第一時間收看我們的影片
不過呢我們在一起著重跟大家分享的是
你知道GPT5這一次的大更新其實同步把很多功能都做了升級嗎
甚至還添加了一些連網路上都找不到的資料
今天我們本著AI神農氏的精神幫大家深挖了8個Chat GPT實用隱藏功能
讓我們直接開始吧 暫停一下 你是不是也被推薦一堆超強的AI工具
結果一打開 你所在的地區無法使用
什麽意思
我就活在這個不該進步的地區嗎
這時候就該祭出我們的神之幹爹Surf shark VPN
一鍵讓你網路瞬移世界各地Surf shark VPN 在全球有100多個位置
擁有超過3,000台伺服器 你想的到的任何AI工具都直上最新的版本
甚至連 BETA 版都可以無痛玩下去
就好比說Google lab里面有一個強大的Google whisk功能
至今已經更新不知道多久了
但台灣用戶還是沒有辦法使用
這時候秒開啟Surfshark VPN直接爽用這些進階功能
你身邊的同事絕對會投以羨慕的眼光
重點來了
如果你是常常在外走跳的人
跟我一樣一定常常需要連線在外面的一些公共Wifi
這時候啟動Surfshark VPN
他就會變成你的專屬網路守門員
完全不用怕你的資訊有外泄的風險
但最讓我感到尊重感的則是Surfshark的clean Web
簡單一句話就是他會移除Google Chrome
Edge Firefox等等瀏覽器三不五時跳出的cookie通知 這功能超好用的
對我們這種瘋狂訂閱然後網站一直會跳通知的人來說呢
真的是爽感直破天氣
而且再而且 你只要注冊一個賬號
你就可以在無限多的裝置使用 蒿羊毛的個性非常符合我們泛科學院的風格
給我們觀眾的夥伴
你只要通過我們的專屬連結進入後
輸入折扣碼Pensicschool馬上讓你獲得額外4個月的使用期
這年頭說實話不裝VPN AI都會對你說啊不好意思
我們只服務特定地區的人類啊
趕緊輸入折扣碼一起跟我們一樣玩遍全球最新的AI工具吧
第一個 你現在可以自訂對話框的顏色 在哪裡呢
在設定裡面然後有一個叫做強調顏色
你現在可以去調整成你喜歡的顏色
比如說把它改成橘色的
那接下來 當我說一個故事
你看右邊這邊就開始變成橘色了
然後你的對話框也會變成橘色
我們在測試的時候有發現說
理論上這些粗體字你把它選起來也會變成橘色的
好那比如說 我們要求他說
好所以你會發現說當你在跟AI做互動的時候他會有給你兩個選項
第一個是思考更長的時間 一個是快速取得回答
這個是GPT5的一個隱藏功能
就是他可以快速的讓你去選擇說你希望他想久一點再給你答案
還是你要快速取得回答
那比如說我現在想要快一點快速取得回答
他就不會花太多時間思考
然後就馬上完成你交給他的工作
那根據我們的測試呢其實你在選擇模型的時候如果你選auto
當他覺得要思考跟快速的時候會讓你自己挑
那要麽你就直接來這個地方直接選擇我要快速就是那就整個對話串
全部都是快速模式在幫你做運作
第三個 就是當初其實對大家罵爆就是這個模型選擇真是做的太爛了
大家就說我想用4o模型
所以Open AI從善如流就把4o模型加了回去
可是呢他現在又多了一個選項叫做在設定里面的show additional models啊
你把這個選項打開重新整理一下
那你現在開個新對話的時候這邊就會有一個叫做thinking mini的模型
然後舊版模型里面 就4o 4.1 o3 o4 MINI的模型偷偷跑出來了
所以原本Open AI為了就是降低他的營運的覆雜性啊
所以他有意識的不希望大家用那麽多模型
讓他的主機可以比較專注在處理特定的模型
但就被他罵了
所以他現在就把這個模型慢慢的放回來
就可以依照你自己的需求去選擇你自己比較想用的模型
當你跟ChatGPT互動的時候
最近就是GPT5更新之後最常被人家罵的
大家覺得模型變得有點無趣
我們好不容易跟4o那時候的模型培養出來的那些感情不見了
那就被大家罵那 所以呢
OpenAI一樣從善如流
那一樣我們現在可以在設定里面找到個人化里面有一個自定指令
自定指令里面呢
他現在有一個叫做ChatGPT該有什麽樣的性格
你可以在這邊直接選啊
你想要一個憤世祭俗的ChatGPT還是機器人的ChatGPT
還是傾聽者 還是極客的ChatGPT
現在任君挑選
那如果你懷念你之前那個不管講什麽都跟你說好棒棒的ChatGPT
那你記得把它改成傾聽者這個模式
那你就可以回到熟悉的ChatGPT的樣子了
接下來呢
我們之前有一支影片講到這個GBT的task任務的功能
那大家其實都會反映說 哎不對啊
我找不到這個任務的選項在哪里 哎他們終於把這個功能給做了回來
你可以直接用提示語的方式要求他去執行一個任務
但是最常遇到的問題就是
執行的任務已經深藏在各種各式各樣的那個對話記錄里面
現在你可以一樣在設定里面
然後找到 排程
然後你就可以按一下管理這邊
你就會看到過去你曾經有執行過的這些任務
那你可以去在這邊調整這個任務的指令啊
或者是調整他的這個時間呢
或是把它按這個暫停或者直接把它刪掉
然後另外在GPT5的模式之下呢
在thinking的模式或者是fast的模式都可以去建立任務
不過因為模型的運作邏輯的不同
所以如果你的任務的內容比較覆雜的話呢
建議優先可以選thinking的模式
然後再去建立任務出來的結果會有所不同
ChatGPT網頁版終於跟上手機版有一個非常非常非常熟悉的icon按鈕在這邊
這個叫做進階語音模式
所以以前這進階語音模式就在手機上能用
現在電腦上也都把它做出來了 以前在電腦上你只能用到standard voice
那現在在電腦板上面你也可以用到這個所謂的進階語音模式
這個模式比較聰明
而且那個聲音會比較自然一點
你今天在跟他互動的時候比如說解釋量子糾纏
那一開始 我們可能選的是自動
然後就自己幫你選模型
然後就給你這個結果
可是 過往我們在ChatGPT聊天的時候
有時候你用著用著又覺得說 這模型太笨了我想要切換模型
但是以前你就要重新開一個新的對話串
現在你可以在他的這個對話的過程的結果這邊
你可以按一下重新生成try again這個按鈕
現在你可以在這地方重新選擇模型
比如說你可以改成換用這個GPT 4.1拿去重新生成剛的那個提問
那除了能夠切換模型之外呢
你也可以在這個地方去讓他變長 新增詳細資料 或者是變短 更加精簡
甚至你可以根據你的需求
比如說當我改寫成5歲小孩能理解的說明
他就可以讓你在對話串里面直接去進一步的去調整這些生產的內容跟格式
不用重新開一個對話記錄
最後一個
這個我們之前有做一支影片叫做Canva code
那Canva code之後呢
我們也做了Gemini的Canvas
然後那GPT也有Canvas
但GPT的Canvas因為模型的更新所以又變得更加的強大
比如說呢
你選擇GBT的這個thinking模式
開啟所謂的畫布模式請制作一個俄羅斯方塊遊戲思考模式
OpenaAI官方有提到GPT5的程式撰寫能力是大幅提升哦
這是官方特別有講的哦
所以在GPT5的這個模式之下
你在要求他寫程式這件事情啊
我覺得之前是不太能打
之前可能是比如說claud或者是Gemini這些模型
但是到了GPT5的時代
我覺得寫程式這件事情他又能夠重新回到牌桌上跟大家掰掰手腕
有機會的話請務必要測試一下
比如說我們的這個俄羅斯方塊遊戲
所以他會先去定義里面的邏輯
然後去把整個遊戲性的核心的那些底層的邏輯結構先想出來
之後再來去寫程式 再來去做那些畫面的呈現
好了
跑程式碼
可以玩了
其實我們在網路上也有看到非常非常多的網友發揮他的創意
比如說做出一些像DJ模擬器啦
鋼琴模擬器啦
什麽太陽系模擬器啦
或者是你也可以試試看去做做看
模擬飛行我們之前Canva code有做過的
以上就是8個我們在這一次的ChatGPT更新之後找到了的隱藏功能
不知道你最喜歡哪一個呢
或者是你有發現哪些我們還沒有發現到的隱藏功能
麻煩在影片下面留言跟我們分享哦
那我們下期再見拜拜